so a few months ago i made why season 1
of game of thrones is so great
and ever since then i've wanted to come
back and look at other seasons
for this video we'll be looking at
season 4 of game of thrones
and we'll be analyzing why is one of the
best seasons in the show
so strap in grab some popcorn and take a
pill of memory loss for season 8 because
i'm about to bring it back to when the
show was at its peak
so for the first aspect as to why season
4 is the best
let's take a look at the subplots within
the season
for game of thrones in general the
majority of the show follows many
different subplots
the only time this wasn't the case was
in season 7 and 8 where most of the
subplots converged and became one main
plot
given that format it was always more
interesting to have a season with
multiple subplots because of the variety
season 4 has about 8 of them and that
offers a vast array of different
settings within the world
it also offers a variety of challenges
like political drama in king's landing
action-oriented conflict at the night's
watch or even a cozy adventure where
characters go on a journey together
season 4 has this variety in spades and
it feels like a well-oiled machine
in terms of pacing because of that we
don't get bogged down from an
overabundance of one element like action
dialogue or adventure
in comparison to season eight where all
the characters are basically crammed
into one setting for half of the season
and it quickly becomes dull and
repetitive sitting around in one place
can get stale
setting wise especially if the writing
is not up to par
i told you i don't want it it doesn't
matter what you want
besides the great variety of subplots in
season 4 let's take a look at their
general
quality most people say that all the
stories for each character
are essentially at their peak within the
show and let's see why that is
so first let's look at daenerys
in season 4 daenerys starts out coming
off of the highs of season 3
and has her unsullied army with that
army
she then takes over marine where she
finally gets to rule
which in of itself is a lot of payoff
the overall progression of the subplot
is perfect
because we get that thrill and action in
the beginning
and then we get the political drama from
her ruling marine
this season's subplot for daenerys
offers something unique for the viewer
by the fact that she becomes a
legitimate ruler of a city for the first
time
that being said this season is basically
peak interest within her overall subplot
for the show
the only season that rivals this is
season 3 where daenerys gets the
unsullied and starts her conquest
the reason why season 4 surpasses this
is because we get a massive hit of
payoff
through her winning marine and from that
payoff
we get even more obstacles from her
being a ruler
so the conflict stays engaging unlike in
later seasons like season 5
where she just sits around running a
city the whole time and the conflict
just stays the same
and because of that it becomes more dull
looking at another big subplot we have
jon snow
most of his story leading up to season 4
is really good
the ultimate payoff from those seasons
comes in season 4 with the watchers on
the wall
and the finale where he confronts mance
raider i reckon you could do it before
any of them could stop you they'll kill
you of course
they'll kill you slow but you knew that
when you came in here both sequences
are regarded as jon snow's best moments
that and his character is objectively
the most interesting in this season
he is both struggling with his love of
the free folk and rose
and he wants to protect his brothers of
the night's watch
so that creates a massive internal
conflict within his character
that is a lot that jon snow has to go
through and in comparison to other
seasons
his character in season 4 is much more
colorful
so again we have another character
subplot at their peak
looking at another main character whose
subplot is at its peak we have
arya lady aaron died
three days ago
[Laughter]
ironically i think arya was the most
interesting when she was traveling with
the hound in season four
despite the cool sounding narrative of
her becoming an assassin in the later
seasons
but in those later seasons arya was
essentially alone
and didn't have that great of a dynamic
with any other character
in season 4 however she has one of the
best in-show dynamics with the hound
arya really changes as a character when
she is with the hound and learns how
dark and grimy the world really is
i just understand the way things are how
many stars they got to behead before you
figure it out
this perfectly shapes her character for
the later seasons
and through the perspective of the hound
we can see her improving
you're learning there are also a ton of
standout moments for these two
characters
practically everything they do or say
becomes a fan favorite moment
this subplot adds a lot of memorable
humor and the hound is the perfect
character to break down arya's innocence
to really turn her into a badass that
and we always have arya clashing with
the hound
which riles them up even more and makes
for some very hilarious moments
overall this is just another perfect
subplot that adds a lot of quality to
the season
there are other subplots that are worth
noting like bran's story which is
fantastic
but i want to turn the attention towards
king's landing
out of all the subplots in the show this
is generally the main one
it houses some of the most interesting
characters and this just allows them to
clash and create iconic scenarios
the first four seasons feature a great
king's landing narrative
but season 4 rises above the previous
seasons and blows us away
the reason why it blows us away is that
the overall season has a major turning
point that drives most of the conflict
and the difference this time is that it
happens early on
unlike in season 1 where it happens
later in the season
season 4 has a massive twist of
joffrey's death
that sets forth most of the conflict
within king's landing
this is going into the third reason and
that is
the turning point by having an already
established cast
you can throw your turning point in the
beginning of the season to really throw
a curveball for your audience
you don't need a lot of character
development in season 4 because your
characters are already set up and game
of thrones knows this
so they jump right into the conflict
which is extremely engaging
in comparison to season 3 there was a
lot of build-up of tension in king's
landing
but not much happened to really push the
plot forward with season 4 however
they take that bold step and thrust
every character into a situation that
creates a gripping conflict
cersei's hatred towards tyrion boils to
an all-time high
tyrion's life is on the line sansa flees
jaime has to deal with potentially
losing his brother tywin has to figure
out how to damage control of the
situation
and the list goes on all of these
characters within season 4
are fundamentally pushed to their limits
by the end of season 3
things were a little too calm and it
started to get too familiar
but season 4 inherently changes that
also this turning point leads to the
best payoff in the show's history
which is the courtroom scene between
tyrion and
tywin through four seasons of build-up
of disdain between these two characters
it all explodes within this moment with
the best delivery coming from tyrion
i did not kill joffrey but i
wish that i had watching your vicious
bastard die
gave me more relief than a thousand
lying
[ __ ] this scene is utterly
heartbreaking
and it even goes higher to create more
conflict by tyrion declaring a trial by
combat
even though this seems like a high point
season 4
somehow snowballs this narrative and it
keeps getting more riveting
we lose hope with tyrion's trial we then
regain that hope with
oberyn pledging to fight for us after
that the hope is squashed in the trial
by combat
and then our hope is finally resurrected
by jaime's rescue
each of these sequences perfectly builds
on the one prior
and this was all because we had a crazy
turning point in the beginning of the
season
by having that turning point in the
beginning of the season we can snowball
the conflict to greater heights
and have an extremely satisfying
conclusion other seasons don't really
capture this magic as well as season 4
because either that turning point
happens at the end of the season for
payoff
or it's the end of the storyline but
season 4 creates that brilliant flow of
escalating conflict
that makes it the most engrossing season
let's take a quick break and look at
this video's sponsor loot crate
loot crate is number one pop culture
subscription based service on the planet
they're dedicated to working closely
with licensed partners like warner bros
disney marvel and more their original
loot crate line is filled with pop
culture collectibles
gear and wearables from comic books film
television animation and more
their january kapow themed crate
features pop culture's fiercest fighters
it includes a he-man t-shirt venom
display standee
fight club soap keychain mortal kombat
classic handkerchief
and a kapow pin use my discount code
supercuts for 15
off your purchase link in the
description now back to the video
one more aspect about the turning point
that makes season 4 better
is the amount of mystery and scheming
that conflict brings into the story
the turning point harkens back to what a
lot of people liked about season 1
and that is a mystery surrounding the
death of a king
in season 1 the story begins with the
death of john aaron
and ned stark gives himself the
objective of finding his
killer this created a cool aura of
mystery within season 1. this ara of
mystery returns within season 4
because it becomes another murder
mystery a lot of what people liked in
season 1
was all the backstabbing and sabotaging
that took place within king's landing
for season 4 this returns and the
sabotaging is as heartbreaking as in
season 1.
the prime example of this is shea's
testimony in the trial because it
utterly breaks tyrion
also because we are in season 4 and are
later on in the show
it makes the mystery more engaging
because we have all the information
about each character and their
relationships
we naturally become more active and
trying to figure out who killed joffrey
in comparison to season one
because we know more about the story the
show trusts the intellect within the
audience
and lets them piece together the mystery
the filmmakers choose not to reveal what
actually happened until season seven
with the farewell of lady olenna tell
sassy
i wanted to know it was me which funny
enough is one of the only good dialogue
scenes in season seven because it has to
do with season four
on top of the backstabbing in king's
landing we also have it in the veil
thanks to littlefinger littlefinger
kills lysa aaron
and that also creates another big plot
of conspiracy
this event also heavily tests sansa and
puts her into one of her first
situations
in which she has to make a big choice
and this goes
back to the point that sansa's journey
in the season
is the most interesting and is at its
peak
overall through the death of joffrey
baratheon and lysa aaron
season 4 is able to capture that same
suspense and mystery
that was so great in season 1. speaking
about the conflict within season 4
let's take a look at another perfect
aspect which is the primary villain
in any good story you need a great
villain that drives a riveting conflict
and thrusts your characters into
challenging situations
for season 4 we have the best villain
within the show
and it's the badass himself tywin
lannister
this character alone has become a
massive icon within the game of thrones
community
his character is beloved despite him
being a villain
and the reason why he's such a beloved
villain is that he is not stereotypical
tywin on his own is a very compelling
character
he is a controlling father who just
wants to have a successful family
and have his kids contribute to the
family's future
this is a very understandable motive and
whenever tywin is clashing with cersei
jaime and tyrion it's hard to really
hate on tywin because we know that deep
down
he is kind of right from his point of
view this was very apparent within
season 3 because he was constantly
clashing with characters around him
through all of that build up in season 3
it allows season 4 to pay it off in its
full
glory the two best examples of this
is cersei's final confrontation with
tywin and tyrion's courtroom challenge
against his father these scenes are
basically regarded as some of the best
scenes from the show
and tywin is to thank for that the only
other villain that has come
close in terms of creating great
conflicting scenes
is joffrey and in the later seasons
they basically disappeared because of
how bad the writing is i'm the man who
killed jimmy
going back to the death of joffrey in
season 4 tywin is able to take an even
bigger villain role
and have more power the ultimate payoff
for this
is when tywin takes a literal seat on
the iron throne
tommen is literally casted aside for
taiwan to step in and make things more
interesting i would say the best fight
scene in the show is between tywin and
tyrion in the courtroom
this is by far the best climax because
the dialogue and pure disdain that these
two characters show each other
is mesmerizing that and charles dance
brings the gravitas to tywin
and almost all of his scenes show a
subtle layer of sinisterism
the way tywin just gives you a death
glare is the most intimidating thing in
the world
his eyes cut through your soul like a
sharp sword and he can't help but feel
like he's about to devour you also i
think tywin as a character
perfectly fits into the conflict of
scheming and backstabbing
he is literally the best at it given
that he orchestrated the ride wedding
the lannisters and there are gods
so knowing that and how powerful he is
as a character
he truly is a force to be reckoned with
given those details it just shows how
much of a massive obstacle he is to
overcome for all the characters
that is why in true game of thrones
fashion
he is destined to have one of the best
show deaths which is
on a toilet the complete irony
so moving away from the villain let's
take a look at another great aspect in
season 4.
for each of the main characters they
essentially go through a major turning
point that heavily affects their future
and personality
for tyrion he decides to kill his father
in an emotional confrontation
this leads into a spell of depression
and he mostly becomes more worn down in
later seasons because of this
for daenerys she makes a tragic decision
to lock away her dragons
this takes a big toll on her mental
health and she starts to lose her
footing in season 5.
for jon snow he hits his lowest point
with the loss of a loved one
and decided to sacrifice himself for the
night's watch by confronting mance
raider
thus proving how much of a hero he is
for arya
she leaves behind the hound who she's
been with for more than two seasons
and she doesn't give him the
satisfaction of death
this validates her character as what the
hound says in later seasons
your cold little [ __ ] aren't you
for cersei she blackmails tywin with the
information of her having sex with jaime
in order to not marry loris tyrell
this essentially gives her a lot more
confidence given that she stood up to
the most powerful person in westeros
everything they say is true about jamie
and me no
your legacy is a lie for jaime
he saves tyrion which results in the
death of tywin
from this jaime thinks he is responsible
for the death of his father
and carries an enormous amount of guilt
in later seasons
and bran finally reaches his destination
and takes on the challenge of becoming
the three-eyed raven
along with what i talked about earlier
with sansa going along with
littlefinger's hostile takeover
all these turning points greatly change
and affect these characters
they aren't just interesting because of
their characteristics
but also from how much they've
progressed in the story
and in season 4 the amount of
progression for these characters
makes them feel more dynamic and
interesting
to contrast this in later seasons we
have jon snow
who barely changes past season 6. so in
general
having your characters evolve makes them
much more fun to follow
and season 4 is the best at this
so for the final reason i need to
address some of the points i stated for
why season one was so
great the three points that still apply
for season four
are efficiency and storytelling great
dialogue
and extraordinary pacing i went into
more depth about them for the video on
season one
but i want to expand a bit more on
efficiency of storytelling and how it
applies to season four
so the prime example for this is the
character oberyn martell
for season four there are a lot of
characters and subplots
so introducing a new and interesting
character is hard to pull off because of
the pure saturation
but with oberyn the show is very
efficient because we simultaneously get
character development
world building for dorne and the
development for a future conflict
the one i keep hearing is that gregor
cleganed the mountain
raped elia and split her in half with
his great sword
also the future conflict tied to his
character
perfectly correlates with what happens
later in the season which makes his
character very relevant to the story
because of his want for revenge towards
the mountain and tywin
this will make him a future ally for
tyrion to contrast this as an example
in season 8 they bring in a new
character for the head of the golden
army
and david and dan include a whole scene
around him only to have it not
matter that is an example of inefficient
storytelling
for oberyn however he is directly
related to the conflict for a personal
reason
and has a direct effect on the outcome
of the story
also the conflict given to us by oberyn
is very concise
and relatable the writing here is top
notch and he can easily get people on
board for a heinous act
like raping and killing children
[Music]
this is a simple trick to give a
sympathy for a character who initially
came off as an [ __ ]
and instead change him into a loving
badass who wants revenge
another aspect of efficient storytelling
in regards to oberyn
is that he encompasses the scope of
dorne what i mean by this is that the
conflict from dorne as a whole
is channeled through his character
oberyn is basically the champion of
dorne
and the concerns from that house can be
fully realized through his character
we are more likely to be interested in
the conflict through one interesting
character
instead of a bunch of angry sand snakes
who have no semblance of character
traits
you want a good girl but you need the
bad [ __ ]
oberyn is just a perfect example of
efficiently building a new character in
a saturated story
by having him have a direct impact on
the overall story
it makes him more important and thus
more compelling
don't leave me alone in this world never
and this is just one primary example of
efficient storytelling
along with the season still having great
dialogue and pacing
so yeah this mostly brings my points to
a close for the video
overall since season 4 still harnesses
the magic of what makes the earlier
season so great
on top of the peak quality subplots the
outstanding turning point in the
beginning
the cool aura of mystery the primary
villain
and each main character's force into a
dire situation that changes them
and because of all that i think season 4
is unmatched
it's hard to beat a large dose of payoff
with riveting subplots that make the
show extremely
entertaining this is why season 4 is the
best season of game
of thrones
you